if my friends sing the wonders of
diversity I try to tell them diversity
isn't a moral good but I end up looking
like some terrible racist why isn't
diversity a moral good well diversity is
a moral good but you can't diversity by
race doesn't produce diversity that's
that's called racism that idea or
diversity of gender doesn't produce
diversity unless that's how you define
diversity look let's say that you get
diversity partly as a consequence of
personality which is a good way of
looking at it there is more diversity
within groups of people than between so
like men and women differ to some degree
in their personalities but there's far
more difference between men within the
male group and women within the male
group than there is between the average
or typical male and female so it's a
stupid wait let's assume that what you
want the organization is pursuing a
complex goal and you want a variety of
skills that would be suited to that goal
then you want there to be enough
diversity of ability within the group so
that the goal can be achieved in a
efficient and and and inexpensive manner
right because what do you want
unofficial tanned expensive obviously
not so there's a presumption that you
get diversity by using identity politics
categories but there's absolutely no
evidence for that whatsoever so that's
why diversity defined by race or
ethnicity or gender is not only not a
moral good it's actually a moral evil
because it dispenses with the whole idea
of the individual dispenses with the
idea of confidence it just replaces it
with the assumption that if you randomly
select from the population because
that's how you would get real equity you
randomly select from the population that
that gives you the best qualified group
of people well that's just that's you
wouldn't do that to select the Plumber
it's it's the stupidest possible way of
selecting for anything randomly you know
there's no difference between selecting
randomly and selecting accidentally so
it
moral diversity defined properly is a
moral good diversity based on identity
politics categories is a positive evil
you know true to our prime ministers
great example of that so back I think it
was in 2015 he announced that half of
his cabinet was going to be women
because it was 2015 or some like
muddle-headed virtue Signori signaling
excuse for not thinking I think only 20%
or 25% of the elected MPs were female so
the proper balance on average would it
be 25 percent female 75 percent male
what he should have done was figured out
who what qualities would make for a
competent cabinet minister because it's
actually quite important to have
competent cabinet ministers and then
selected from among his people for
nothing other than competence but he
could virtue signal and then he set up
the most important board let's say of
the entire country on a quasi random
basis Jesus how pathetic he should have
been pilloried by Canadians for that but
we're so clued out and and also in the
situation that you described it's like
if I say well 50% of Trudeau's cabinet
shouldn't have been women it's like oh
you're a misogynist it's like no only
25% of the elected officials were women
now you might say well it would be
better if 50% of that were elected it's
like maybe it would be better but it
didn't happen so you can't you can't fix
it at the top end it was appalling so
it's a hard argument to make you know
because you need to know that there's
more difference within groups than
between them in order to be able to come
up with a credible argument you know and
then so yeah